Yeah, I had um I had three topics that I
was wanted to ask you about.
>> Sure.
>> Um the first one, I don't mean for it to
sound shallow. I was interested in like
the whole like family planning and
contraception because I had a hard time
wrapping my mind around that part of
Catholicism.
>> Yeah. Well, I that's a good question. I
have to learn myself because Catholic
Church does not allow artificial
birth control. In fact, it's from my
understanding, and I have to keep it
G-rated, they also disallow what's
called kitus interruptus.
>> That's a Latin term. I'm not trying to
sound intelligent. I learned that
actually from reading the hadiths. Kitus
interruptus means that if you are being
intimate with your spouse, guys, I'm
going to try to keep it G-rated. I'm
trying. There is no pulling out.
No, that I know you're laughing at that,
but I'm just telling you.
>> Yeah.
>> So, they believe that one main purpose
of marriage is to be fruitful, multiply,
subdue the earth. And children are a
blessing heritage from the Lord. And so
then to try to interrupt that blessing
is the sin against God's mandate for
marriage.
[clears throat] So, anything that will
hinder you from having as many children
as you can is a sin against God. It's
it's a satanic attempt to override God's
purpose for marriage.
>> Okay.
>> So that's nutshell. That's what it is.
>> Okay. And then like even like
financially like
>> Well, that's why you have to trust in
the Lord, brother. [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> See, that's that's a in fact, if you
look at it, you'll find in some of the
poorest countries, they have the largest
families, and yet they still survive,
don't they?
>> That's true.
>> Isn't that the case?
It would seem so. Yes.
>> Yeah. If you go to some of the poorest
countries that are not as advanced
technologically,
you'll find they have some of the
largest families and they still survive.
They still get along fine. Their
children still grow up, right? So this
is another attempt by Satan and the
powers that be as your father would say
conspiracy theory to try to discourage
you and scare you from trusting God and
fulfilling his mandate to have as many
church children as possible and trusting
the goodness and the grace of our Lord
to never leave you
>> begging [clears throat] for bread. It's
one of the promise scripture for the
righteous. Now that doesn't mean there
won't be hard times you won't suffer.
means that in spite of it, God will give
you the grace to endure and you will be
able to manage, right? I mean,
>> Jesus, our Lord himself was born in a
very poor home. Now, in his context, his
holy mother
could not would not have children after
him. But if we go with the oldest
tradition, Joseph was a widowerower and
he had already had several children
prior to
him being entrusted with the custodian
of Mary and Jesus. But nonetheless, my
point is if you see what this fear
of not having enough has done to
societies that supposedly advance, have
you seen China and Japan and other
countries where because they look down
upon having many children? In fact, at
one time
the government in China
had actually [clears throat] made it
mandatory to have no more than one child
and they would abort any other
pregnancy. But now you see they're in
economic disaster, aren't they? Because
they don't have enough youth to replace
the older people to sustain the economy.
See, when you don't do it God's way, it
leads to disaster and collapse, doesn't
it?
>> Yeah, it definitely looks like that. I
know my wife's probably happy with that
answer, too. She wants to have like a a
lot of children. So, [laughter]
>> let's look at it from another angle. If
you look at just the white
I don't know what the term to use white
race white anyway if you notice
the white
should I say race is that a term I don't
know because you can be you can be white
you can be Jewish you can be black you
can be Jewish but I'm saying just the
white men in general because the average
household
there's only one or two children
>> they are a dying breed within a 100
years the white [clears throat] man is
going to be nearly extinct because of
this fear of having multiple children.
But do you notice in [clears throat]
America the the ones that have the
largest families are the Hispanic and
the black communities
>> and they're not going to be going
anywhere. They're not going to be going
extinct anytime soon because they have
larger number of children. So they
sustain their ethnicity and their race
and their values.
>> Right?
So you see how if you do it God's way,
it works out at the end. But if you do
it your way or you do it Satan's way and
justify it, you become
a breed that will pretty much be wiped
out of existence because you're going to
be extinct sooner than later. And that's
why they have a fear in Europe. One of
the fears in Europe, what is it? That
because of migration, the Muslims are
coming in. They're having more children
than native Europeans. So that within 50
years it'll be a Muslim majority and
those European Europeans that were born
in Europe will soon [clears throat] go
into extinction and that Europe will
simply be Arabia
>> because of this teaching that having too
many children is a detriment not a
blessing.
>> Right. Okay, that makes uh perfect sense
actually.
Um so mainly it's like it would be good
for the community basically.
>> Well it's it's preservation
of the human race and the particular
tribe
ethnicity and culture because the Lord
said be fruitful multiply and subdue the
earth.
>> That's what he says. The first command
he gives in Genesis 1
to Adam male and female is be fruitful,
multiply, subdue the earth. Meaning have
so many children that you now subdue the
earth because God created the earth and
gave it to mankind to rule over. So when
you don't do it God's way, your
particular people group, your particular
race, your particular tribe will go into
extinction. they won't be around
anymore. Why [clears throat] do you
think in Israelite law if a man died
childless Deuteronomy 25 to10 as the
spirit gives me clarity of speech and
thought and perfect exes Jesus I don't
want to mislead anyone why do you think
it was mandatory
that if a man died childless I'm married
and you're my younger brother if a man
died childless
Deuteronomy 25 to10 this is called the
lever law his brother would then have to
take the widow
and then get her pregnant to have a
child for his deceased brother in order
for his line to be preserved through
that child.
And if any brother failed to do his due
diligence and his duty in preserving the
line of his brother, he was actually
considered to be an ingrate, considered
to be evil. In fact, let me show you the
command.
>> Okay?
You see how important it is to preserve
lineage.
>> Yeah, it's a lot deeper than I was
thinking.
>> And to have no children was considered a
curse from God. That's how the
Israelites viewed it. Now, that's not
always the case. Sarah was barren, but
she wasn't cursed. She was beloved by
God.
Even for a period of time, Rebecca
couldn't get pregnant. If you follow the
chronology, Genesis 24:25,
Isaac marries her when he's about 40,
but she only gets pregnant when he's
around 60, 20 years later. And yet, she
gives birth to twins. And then Leah and
Rachel. Rachel could not get pregnant at
the get-go. Leah could. Rachel finally
gave birth to two sons and died as she
was giving birth to the last one. Then
you had Elizabeth. And tradition says
even the blessed parents of the holy
mother, the grandparents of Christ, they
too could not have children because
Mary's mother Anna, similar to Elizabeth
and similar to even Samuel's mother, the
prophet, ironically, the prophet
Samuel's mother's name was Hannah. And
the maternal grandmother of our Lord,
his mother's mother, her name was
Hannah. Tradition says like the Hannah,
the mother of Samuel, this Hannah, the
mother of Mary, the grandmother of
Christ, too could not conceive and she
only conceived miraculously in her older
years as a miracle because she gave
birth to the holy blessed virgin who' be
the mother of God in the flesh. Now my
point being
it was not necessarily the case that if
someone couldn't have children they were
cursed because in the case of Sarah she
was loved and blessed case of Rebecca
case of Rachel case of Hannah the mother
of Samuel and Anna the maternal
grandmother of our Lord Elizabeth the
mother of John these were women loved by
the Lord but society thought if you
didn't have children that means God has
put a curse on you and wants to wipe out
your line he wants your lineage to end
maybe because you did something so
heinous in the sight of God that God
doesn't want your lineage to continue
and that wasn't always the case. Now let
me show you how important this is.
Deuteronomy 25 5-10.
Everyone following with me so far?
Right? Let me enlarge your screen a
little more.
[clears throat and cough]
So having a lot of children God says is
a blessing. So we have to trust God. I
know it's hard. It's scary.
But this is where you have to die to
your fears and trust in God. God will
provide.
And look at
these poor countries. They have large
families and they're surviving. Their
children grow up to have families of
their own.
>> Right?
>> So it comes down to trust. And it's
hard. May God destroy our fears, doubts,
unbelief, and give us perfect faith,
hope, and love. And make us doers of the
his word, not be hypocrites. Now, here
it is. Deuteronomy 25 5-10.
If brothers dwell together and one of
them dies and has no son, the wife of
the dead shall not be married outside to
a stranger. She can't marry someone
else. Why? Her husband's brother shall
go into her, take her as his wife, and
perform the duty of a husband's brother
to her. His duty to his brother. What is
his duty? It shall be that the firstborn
whom she bears shall succeed in the name
of his brother who is dead. that his
name not be blotted out of Israel. See
how important it is to have children?
>> You die without a child. If you're
living under the old covenant, your
brother Joshua would have to marry her
and sire a child for you so that your
line doesn't die out.
>> Right?
>> But what if Joshua refused to honor you
by preserving seed for you? If the man
doesn't want to take his brother's wife,
then his brother's wife shall go up to
the gate to the elders and say, "My
husband's brother refuses to raise up to
his brother a name in Israel." In other
words, my brother-in-law is so pathetic
that he doesn't care that his brother's
lineage is going to die out.
He doesn't care that his brother's
lineage, his name will not endure in
Israel. This how wicked he is. He will
not perform the duty of a husband's
brother to me. Then the elders of his
city shall come call him and speak to
him. If he stands and says, "I don't
want to take her." Then his brother's
wife shall come to him in the present
elders and loose his sandal from off his
foot and spit in his face.
See where I get spitting in people's
face from. [laughter]
She shall answer and say, "So shall it
be done to the man who does not build up
his brother's house." See this what will
be done to you? You will be disgraced,
humiliated, and have her spit in your
face as a sign. You see how wicked this
guy is? He had no love for his brother
because he didn't care that his
brother's name would die out because he
didn't sire an offspring to continue his
brother's lineage. His name shall be
called in Israel, the house of him who
had his sandal removed. Now, here's
what's interesting.
This law was already known and observed
long before Moses cottified it. I need
everyone to learn listen you guys on
Rumble as well. I haven't forgotten you.
Make Rumble great again here. This law
that was codified by Moses was already
known before it was written down. How do
I know? Because in Genesis 38, Judah,
who becomes the ancestor of our Lord
Jesus Christ, because Jesus from the
child of Judah, he had a son named Eer
who married. But he was so wicked, God
struck him dead before he had a child.
Judah then told his brother Onan, "Go
into your brother's wife, get her
pregnant in order to have offspring for
your brother." So his line will
continue. It says that Onan was so
wicked that whenever he went in and
slept with his brother's widow before
he could get her pregnant, he would
spill out his semen because he didn't
want to get her pregnant with a child
for his brother. And God then killed him
dead.
>> Yeah. Genesis 38.
>> Wow.
>> Right here. At that time Judah went down
from his brothers and visited a certain
Adulomite whose name was Ha. There Judah
saw the daughter of a certain Canaanite
man named Shua. He took her
and went into her. She conceived and
bore a son and his name and he named
him. She conceived again and bore a son
and she named him Onan. She had again
bore a son and named him Sheila. He was
at Khaze when she bore him. Judah took a
wife for his firstborn or heir and her
name was Tamar. Judah's firstborn was
wicked in Yahweh's sight. Whatever he
did, God was disgusted with him and
struck him dead. So killed him. Judah
said to an end, now remember this is
four years before Moses in the law.
[clears throat] Go into your brother's
wife and perform the duty of a husband's
brother to her. Raise up offspring for
your brother. Now he didn't say no.
Like Deuteronomy 25, the brother said,
"No, I won't do it." He goes, "Okay."
But his intention wasn't to get her
pregnant with an offspring for his
brother. His intention was to enjoy her
sexually.
So he wanted the free sex, but not the
responsibility
>> of siring a child for his brother
because he didn't say no. What did he
do? Look what he did.
>> Mhm.
>> Ona knew the offspring wouldn't be his.
And he went into his brother's wife. In
other words, he slept with her anyway.
He spilled his semen on the ground lest
he should give offspring to his brother.
When God saw that, he killed him dead,
too.
See how serious it was?
>> Mhm.
>> So, you understand how serious this is?
So, this is the passage, by the way,
that I've seen Catholics use to condemn
what's called quitus interruptus. Quitus
interruptus means spilling your seed,
pulling out.
This is the passage I've seen them
quote. Now, in the context, he did it
for a different reason. He didn't want
her to get pregnant with his brother's
child because he didn't want to sire a
child for his brother. It may be he
hated his brother. He saw his brother
was wicked and he just wanted his line
to end.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. But this is what's called kitus
interruptus.
>> Okay.
>> So, this is why the Catholic Church is
very strict. No kitus interruptus,
no artificial birth control. Very
strict. In fact, I've been told, now I
haven't confirmed this. I'm just telling
you what I've heard that up until 1930s,
all the churches in the west, the
Catholic church, Protestant churches
condemned artificial birth control and
were on the same page. It was only in
the 1930s where the Protestants started
laxing these commandments that
you find now among Protestant circles
Protestant pastors permitting artificial
birth control whereas the Catholic
Church has maintained its position right
[clears throat] and has not compromised
on that issue.